it's more like a personal strength that
I feel like I have more than I've ever
felt before because I was able to make
steps for my future and for my present
and so I just feel more confident as
well and Sister Wives star Christine
Brown's continuing to take more steps in
making her new chapter official living
my life every day day to day I would say
it's so much better after relocating to
Utah last year following her split from
X Cody Brown Christine reveals she's
finally started filming the TLC series
from her new home she captions a selfie
I'm finally filming in my house in Salt
Lake so excited I started moving forward
and I just don't I don't I didn't look
back I never looked back I just started
moving forward I just been having
but just more fun and getting truly
around her siblings more around my mom
more and my dad I've just been able to
hang out with family my brothers and
sisters yeah my parents my kids more
often than ever before
Christine's big move away from the
family in Arizona is now playing out on
Sister Wives I still stand firm that
leaving is 100
the right thing to do
and fans got a glimpse of how Cody feels
about it I'm just a guy who just doesn't
hold back
man just the knife in the kidneys over
all these years and the sacrifices that
I made to love you wasted you're like
I'm divorced
I'm leaving I'm done with you you're out
of my house
instead of actually making the
relationships work I could sit here and
dissect everything that Cody has said
and give you my point
but we've done this for years
I'm tired it's hard when you live it and
then when you get to see it and relive
it again it's very difficult emotionally
so right now while the episodes are
airing it's all very raw again but
despite all the tension between Cody and
Christine the mom of six has no plans to
stop filming the TLC series I made like
a promise to like Cody and everybody
else and I will stay with Sister Wives
as long as we have the show just to be
fair it's what our family's been doing
for so long and so no I absolutely I
feel like it would be disloyal if I you
know decided to not be part of the show
ask for a potential Christine spin-off
series well she's all for it dude I'm
totally open no idea what it looks like
but absolutely that'd be just fun as
heck
[Music]